GILBERT STRANG: OK?
Now, finally, a
nonlinear equation.
Growth, but it's-- the growth
is cut off by competition--
slowed down my competition.
Let me show you the equation.
In a way, it's the
simplest nonlinear equation
I could think of.
We have the usual
dy/dt equal ay.
That would give
exponential growth.
The growth would go on forever.
But then, as y
gets large-- if we
think of y as the population,
so the growth is exponential
when the birth rates higher than
the death rate, and we grow.
We have-- and that's
what's happening.
But our world population is
not growing pure exponentially,
forever.
And this is a simple
term, a simple model not,
very accurate, but it's
the right place to start.
For competition, when
you have too many people,
somehow the
multiplying y times y
gives you a number of
interactions of all the y
people with themselves.
And those interactions--
that competition slows down
the growth, and so the
coefficient there is negative.
We want to solve that non-linear
equation and learn from it.
And it's called the
logistic equation.
That's-- it's got to
be a famous example.
And it has a neat trick that
allows you to solve it easily.
Let me show you that trick.
The trick is to let z--
bring in a new z as 1/y.
Then, if I write
the equation for z,
it will turn out to be linear.
So you see, I'm always
hoping, and here succeeding,
to get back to a
simple linear equation.
And this device happens
to work for this problem.
We need, in the end,
a more systematic way
that would work
for other problems,
like there could be
some constant term
there from harvesting, from
the changing the equation.
Let me go with this one.
So what's the equation
for z then, dz/dt.
The derivative of that,
that's y to the minus 1
is minus 1 y to the minus
2 times dy/dt, right?
The derivative of y
the minus 1 is minus 1,
y to the minus 2 times
the derivative of dy/dt.
But now dy/dt is ay
minus by squared.
And what do I have?
I've got a, with a
minus, ay over y squared.
That will be z.
So that's minus az.
Minus minus giving me a plus b.
y squared over y squared
is just a constant.
Look at the equation for z now.
Couldn't be better.
dz/dt is minus az
and plus a constant.
And we know the solution
to that equation.
So I can write down the
solution to that equation.
And I will.
Then, I just take y to
be 1 over that solution.
Maybe, I'll just write
y straight ahead.
I'll just write the
answer y, which is 1/z.
And z is the solution
to this equation.
And let me see.
So I'm going to
have an exponential,
but it's going to be-- the
exponential e to the minus at
is going to show up in z.
And they'll be more there.
It will show up in z.
And then when I do
1/z to get back to y,
that exponential is going
into the denominator.
That's what's new.
Let me get the
whole thing correct.
I have a a.
Otherwise, these are constants
d here and b goes there.
And I just have to tell
you what the d is there.
d is going to involve the
initial value, y of 0.
At time 0, we start
somewhere, y of 0.
And we'll begin to grow.
We'll grow.
But with the slowing down
term keeping us back.
And, in the end, it
can't grow forever
because that term becomes
bigger than that one.
If y went on and on increasing,
then it can't happen.
So it really is--
it can only increase
while this is
positive, and that's
only positive below that line.
Here's what the curve does.
It goes upward, but
then it has to-- it
can't cross that line
because above that line,
for big Y-- above
that line for big Y
this negative term means
that the slope is negative.
If I started with a big
number, I'd have to come down.
But can I just
draw that picture?
But it's really between
here-- between these lines
that I'm thinking the
world population is.
So it started way back at
some time minus infinity.
And it-- whatever.
It came up to time 0.
This is t equals 0,
starting population.
And, of course, t equals
0 could be the year 2000.
We can move the time
axis as we want.
So t equals 0 might
be the year 2000.
Our population is
still increasing,
but it won't go on forever.
And it will slow down and
approach this limit a/b--
approaches a/b.
So that number a/b is totally
special for this equation.
And let me think
about that part.
And we give a name
to this curve.
It's often called
a logistic curve.
That's OK.
But I like the name S curve.
It's an S curve.
In some way-- or
a Sigmoidal curve.
In some way, it looks a bit like
an S, a very stretched out S.
So that-- and you see
why-- do you-- just
takes like-- look here.
As t goes to infinity,
this becomes 0.
When t gets large, this
exponential is gone.
And I just have a
or b at the limit.
When t is minus infinity,
way back at starting time--
when t is minus infinity,
that's a giant number.
This is-- I'm dividing
by a giant number.
I'm at 0.
So way back at time minus
infinity, it started from 0.
Those two possibilities ,
y equals 0 and y equal a/b,
are the key things to
see for this equation.
So I'm going to
take a few minutes
to see where do those come in.
Those are steady states.
Let me use that word and
show you what I mean.
Steady states, critical
points, for my equation dy/dt.
Let me write the
logistic equation again.
A steady state is a value of
y where the derivative is 0.
Nothing happens.
It just sits there.
So if that is 0--
so a steady state--
let me use those capital
Y for a steady state.
Those are just numbers.
They are the numbers where this
is 0, ay minus by squared is 0.
You see that if
I start out at y,
at capital Y, a steady
state, that is 0.
The derivative is 0.
I stay there.
And there are two possibilities.
If I start-- this gives me
two possibilities, right?
What are the solutions
to this equation?
This gives me y equals 0
is one solution clearly.
Or y equals-- let's see.
If this equals that,
I could cancel a y.
y would be a/b, exactly
the two in the picture.
If I start at 0, I stay at 0.
No population.
Nothing can happen.
But if I move a little away,
if I get two people, we grow.
We grow exponentially
for awhile,
but then the by squared term
takes it-- gets in there,
slows us down.
And we slow down, and
we reach this a/b.
If we had started at a/b,
we would have stayed at a/b.
So that S curve
picture is really
a nice graph of the solution.
Here is the solution at
steady state, going nowhere.
There is a solution at
steady state with population,
competition, and cooperation are
balanced, and nothing happens.
Otherwise, whenever we have S
curves, then they don't cross.
Depending where we're--
depending on the initial value,
we'll get beyond one or
other of these curves.
And they all go up to
that carrying capacity,
that limiting population, a/b.
So the final take home
message about this equation
is, as an example of
equations with steady states,
this steady state
is called unstable
because if we start near
y equals 0, we take off.
If we start near y equals
0, we start growing.
We leave that steady state.
This steady state
is called stable
because if we're near a/b, we
get closer and closer to a/b.
I'll do the example.
This will be one example
of a general problem.
dy/dt is some function of y.
It's a right-hand side
that depends on y.
That will be our next
video, to understand
those equations dy/dt
is f of y and notice
that they're not linear.
But we can solve
for steady states.
A steady state will
be when f at y is 0.
Then, nothing happens.
But is that steady state stable?
Or is it unstable?
That's the crucial thing
for all applications.
Are we settling down to
something acceptable?
Or are we blowing up to
something impossible?
That's the next video.
Thank you.